[Musique]
non
c'était il y a trente ans en 1988 le
premier câble à fibre optique traverse
l'atlantique dans le monde des
communications
il marque une véritable révolution il va
permettre de multiplier les liens entre
paris londres et new york
c'est le câble du futur
[Musique]
le nouveau câble doit relier l'amérique
du nord à l'europe de tak olten au nude
josi il se déploie sur 6680 kilomètres
près de 90% de son parcours sous l'océan
atlantique avant d'atteindre 20 mars en
france et white wolf au royaume uni
déjà dans les années 50 et 60 on a
multiplié l'installation de câbles
téléphoniques sous marins dans
l'atlantique mais ce sont des câbles
coaxiaux en cuivre le volume d'appels
simultanés qui peuvent transmettre est
limité et la communication par satellite
risque de ne pas fournir la morde la
fibre optique offre une option inespéré
celle de faire voyager à plus grand
nombre d'appels grâce à un signal
numérique
transporté par la lumière le câble
transatlantique à fibre optique va
permettre de transmettre 40 et
communications simultanées dix fois plus
qu'un câble conventionnel
dans les années soixante dix devil
installe des réseaux souterrains de
câbles à fibre optique
le défi est désormais de passer d'un
réseau terrestre
un câble sous marin les ingénieurs des
laboratoire etienne thibert aux états
unis s'attelle à la tâche ils doivent
construire des systèmes robustes
capables de résister aux conditions sous
marine
comme ces répéteurs de signal disposés à
intervalles réguliers au fond de l'océan
ils doivent également s'assurer de la
fiabilité de ses équipements de
transmission sur une aussi longue
distance le câble qui fait à peine 2 cm
de diamètre comprend six fibre optique
autour desquels se dresse une armature
de câbles d'acier
entouré d'un tuyau de cuivre autour
duquel se greffe un élastomère c'est
selon câble qu'on hisse à bord du navire
le cs landes lines a été spécialement
conçu pour l'installation de câbles sous
marins
c'est à son bord qu'on va procéder à
tous les tests en mer ainsi qu'au
déploiement du câble dans l'océan
atlantique
à des profondeurs pouvant atteindre
plusieurs kilomètres le câble sera
déposé sur le fond marin où il va
épouser la topographie du sol près des
côtes à faible profondeur
le câble sera enfouie dans une tranchée
pour le protéger des engins de pêche qui
pourraient l'accroché en touchant le
fond marin
la mise en service de ce premier câble
transatlantique à fibre optique se fera
en 1988
dès lors la majorité des communications
entre l'amérique et l'europe
emprunteront cette nouvelle route une
route de verre et de lumière
là